hey guys hello welcome to the stream
today I am Sam
you guys might remember me from a couple
weeks ago although if you have you
weren't there
hello Joey I um fuzz and we are gonna be
playing Celeste today it is a really
cool platformer that was made by Matt
makes games and yeah you ready to jump
into it yes very ready is there anything
that you want to tell tell the guys
before we cut to the game um well I feel
like don't the games game on to
notoriety right now just because of how
difficult it is it's one of those very
like hard platformers I guess otherwise
doing that's platformers where you just
die a whole lot but in the same sense
you learn a whole lot from doing that
are there any other for people who are
watching that aren't really into
platformers like vacuum can you explain
what it's platformer is I guess is just
one like similar to Super Meat Boy where
you you learn the level just by a dying
over and over falling into abyss is a
lot so on so it's a messy learning
experience yeah but it's it's it's fun
it's it's it's satisfying to do that
alright let's jump right in I guess yeah
sweet
yo Eric well anyway we can start for
right now um so I I figure like the best
thing for us to do maybe is kind of go
through the first maybe the first one or
two levels so you just kind of show off
what it actually looks like and how it
plays and then we can go on to the much
harder ones so I'm just gonna start off
with the Forsaken city it's the the
first level I know so I think some
people in the chat were like no spoilers
so I'm gonna skip a lot of the story
stuff because does have a good story I
had one job guys okay so I'm just gonna
be speeding through a lot of this kind
of showing you guys what the game looks
and sounds like cuz the soundtrack is
also really really great
yeah it has a 8-bit style that's both
musically and aesthetically I if it's so
if you guys I don't know other games
that Matt make memes may that's very
similar to towerfall ascension and some
of these other games that all have very
similar style
joking explain what this level is here
okay so this level is the Forsaken city
it's the first one and this is kind of
where you get to learn a lot of the
mechanics in the game where you can walk
around you can jump I can also do
there's no the wall cling just by
folding the right trigger can hold on to
walls and you have jump around from
there and the main mechanic here in the
game is this - right here and this will
get you a lot of mileage just being able
to clear gaps and just sort of add to
your jumps so the wall - and the I mean
the wall cling and the - together are
basically the two moves that you're
gonna continuously utilize throughout
the whole game yeah together and so like
every every single level they they
introduce a new mechanic that will oh my
gut that will you'll be able to learn
and kind of a they build off of that so
well hey goob good to see you in the
chat yes that is the the wall cling has
a stamina bar right yeah playing forever
can't cling forever you can do it you
can hold on to place for like a good
amount of time so like think about what
you're gonna do but like once you start
moving the timer starts ticking down and
you got it you got to hurry up so the
game like encourages you to just keep
moving trying to find like hats in order
to the clear each screen because there's
not a lot of there's not a lot of spots
where you can like take a breather and
like think about it for a little bit
yeah it's kind of like you have to
operate really well under pressure and
figure out the puzzle at the same time
yeah so for people who love like intense
puzzle experiences probably Joe you've
sort of become our like resident 2d
platformer guy yeah I think up heads
like when I started playing that I got
really into it and I guess everyone
knows that game as being like really
tough but I like I just loved it so much
I just wouldn't stop playing it
cr7 humma this game is Celeste it is by
Matt makes games
he also made towerfall ascension and a
bunch of other platformers tension was
the that was like the big one yeah that
was a big one that he got popular for
and if you don't know that off the top
of your head you probably have seen even
maybe us play it in the past here yeah
like on some extra life livestream
probably yeah it's like a four player
survival of the fittest
yes style game where you have to shoot
arrows at each other and use different
things to you know you have to be the
last man standing
yeah if you if you go look it up you
might be familiar with it because it was
quite popular for a while alright so go
through that one and then I'll go
through the second one because I cleared
that one already what have you gotten
through the whole game yeah so basically
the entire game is about seven chapters
long and then hidden in every chapter
there is a there unlockables everywhere
so you have your regular unlockable
which is right there you can kind of see
it's a strawberry yes and these are kind
of just like extra challenges that you
can do like this ones in a spot with
like a bunch of spikes so you can try to
get to it you don't they're not really
necessary but it's just a cool little
thing that they've added to difficulty
for people who want that yes there are
the heart I mean there's the
strawberries and there's also parts that
you can get yeah I'm eating the more
difficult versions which are the b-side
levels yeah so for you guys who haven't
seen this game before the b-side is the
if they're like cassette tapes that are
hidden and like fringe areas yes level
and they unlock just a really really
super hard version of it yeah so if you
if you get through the game and you
realize like man that was really
difficult it's just getting started yeah
some people in the hello
dinosaurs man is Sam nudity yes or she
just one of the her first video
appearances I am NOT new to GS I am
normally social media
sir here I've been here for about nine
months
so sort of new in those yeah a spectrum
of things and I have been on one stream
in the past so it's a wonderful to meet
you thanks for coming by I have a
request
yes can you turn up the music for this
part because this is when it gets really
good absolutely
Erik AJ if you're watching I'm sorry if
I'm SSS touch the controls do it very
slowly ask it is that nice yeah so I'm
gonna skip this cutscene because people
want this music is dope
I agree so like I said each area
introduces a new mechanic that you'll
use the whole level and this one you got
like lose a little space blob squares
that if you - in - it just keeps going
and you can jump out the other side I
don't know but I would like to call it
space jello yeah I think that's fine
yeah so like if you if you run into a
wall for example will just die so you've
got to be careful because he can't stop
the other side and there's a few
different objects like this in the game
that you can like transport through
right not just space jello blocks but
there's also
that little feather thing yeah so
there's like a lot each level will have
something Errol M says when games have
great music it makes the experience so
much better though era i completely
agree I think that I when I think of my
favourite games I always remember songs
for me because that's like just give so
much like that's what sticks with you
all right
got something chasing me let's go
are you sad no she's not slow she's
going the exact same speed as me so
she's kind of yeah so still like I feel
near everything that you do so you gotta
keep moving
can't just stop your cuz you go
[Music]
gube says would you say it's a metro
that maybe is not really there's not any
there's no backtracking oh yeah rebels
are very linear whereas like a
Metroidvania game is it's supposed to be
more stacked and exploratory yeah
there's like oh you pick up up power up
here and then like we visit some other
area to pick them out that's yeah it's
not really how it works it's all just
about like the main thing that changes
really is your skill like as you return
you can always return to you know just
older levels yes and what's gonna unlock
is like paths that you never thought you
could take before because you didn't
learn how to do that like the jumps are
all different or the jumps it's like
you'll learn new things basically now I
have a question now once you get to the
end of the game I know that there is
and I'm not trying to not spoiling
anything for anybody I just am speaking
to things that you have to collect the
unlock parts of the game yet there is a
level of where you have I mean at the
very end there's a like bonus level
where you have to have hearts anyway
that you can get hearts is by beating
the b-sides mm-hmm so even the game is
linear to finish and basic experience
can you go back and find the beats eyes
and achieve them yes
so you can always return to it like
they're always a lot for you but once
you get to them so the b-sides are there
yeah there's no like retroactively
having to go find the bees
[Music]
squid wizard shoutouts to you that still
is a good wizard is my old co-worker
Andrew thank you for coming by to check
out the street good
so I also know that this game it can be
quite challenging but for people who are
really just interested in the story
straight up there is a sort of easy mode
yeah so what they have in like in the
main menu you can turn on an assist mode
which basically will modify certain
aspects of the game and it will I guess
it'll make it easier but like you can
you can customize it basically to
however you to your liking so you can
you know turn the speed down to like 50%
you can give yourself unlimited stamina
to hold on or you can even give yourself
invincibility mmm if you just want to
focus on my climbing is this available
for iOS and Android I don't believe so I
think this is ps4 PC and switch yes I
believe yeah why is Joey oh he's so good
at super hard platformer I wish I wish I
could explain that myself like I don't
feel like I'm great at it but when I
think this game really does well is ease
you into that difficulty and makes you
learn a lot of stuff like very gradually
like a lot of stuff that I'm doing like
a lot of climbs and a lot of the ways
I'm traversing these levels I had no
idea I'd be able to do that when I first
started this game I was like plugging
along really really slowly so something
this game does do well is teach you the
mechanics yeah it's like a nice learning
curve there also I was gonna ask you and
this is like sort of a you know a side
question but did you play a lot of 2d
fighters when you were growing up yes
because it is my theory the people who
played a lot of 2d fighters are
naturally kind of good at platformers
because they just have the I for I guess
the frames and I don't know oh yeah yeah
you know I guess so because like I was
thinking about also just thinking about
how each level each screen in the game
is kind of like its own
it's only like its own like standalone
challenge and a lot that reminds me of
like oh this is similar to me trying to
figure out a combo and like working in
training mode to get that like perfect
yeah it's sort of like this because it's
a similar like you know you're a
sequence of button presses and trying to
get like frame perfect and everything
exactly so that makes sense I think so I
hear you on that all right
chapter complete so we what do the first
two levels are weren't too bad so we're
actually gonna go let's go back to the
first one and we're gonna do the B side
as you can see there's a lot more spikes
here yes and believe it or not this is
the first time I'll ever recommend it
but if you if you guys really likes less
and want to get it on switch play with
the joy cons because I think that's the
ideal way to go I like I know people
really love the pro controller but I
could never really get a handle of it
for this game just because the d-pad
since its split up into four buttons I
feel like it's a lot easier to have like
more precise movement
[Music]
I know those once you switch I'm not
sure how competitive that was like I
just want to see like a tournament with
everybody rolling in bringing their own
like custom ones how do you play Wow use
the pro controller I can't even imagine
yeah it's mostly because like the d-pad
on the pro controller I feel like
there's a little finicky like I'll be
pressing forward and then the slightest
tilt towards the up position will give
me an up forward which is not really
great in a game like this to have right
it's gonna make you may be a little more
sloppy yeah there's like this I know
what's left and what's right
so I know Joey that you love the actual
gameplay yeah
can you speak to the story doll or did
you just like speed no actually the
story was probably the most surprising
part of it because I wasn't really
expecting you know much from like a
platform like this usually games like
this they don't really I guess they they
typically don't have like a like a
storyline is focused a lot on the
gameplay yeah on the other side of that
but like all the mechanics and all the
the difficulty actually ties in really
well with with the story I think I don't
want to spoil anything I won't spoil I
think but you know it's it's a very good
very very good yes how that says I can't
play pixel games anymore I'm tired of
them play too many since the 90s
even if gameplay is amazing with a
mind-blowing story eventually get bored
with the visuals I guess that's a fair
that's fair you know each their own yeah
oh my god the spikes give me anxiety I
please I played a lot of Super Meat Boy
yeah there's some ways you just you just
turn into the story is surprisingly
[Music]
so the thing you're trying to achieve
here is oh yeah so I got and then gonna
get over here to ride that platform back
so I can get into the into that
midsection there really really take me
go
when is Joey gonna get into the soul
zest slash get good game
oh I have to say I love the genre
renamed baguette baguette Beauty games
games like we're talking about like it's
super grinding like Dark Souls yeah
there's there's a slight difference
between like those kinds of games and
then like ones like these similar to cut
that because I think just people in
general like you like oh it's the Dark
Souls or whatever yeah I mean it's cool
that they have like made a name for
themselves by like a difficult yeah
genre you know Dark Souls
it is difficult and sometimes like
claiming that Dark Souls is difficult is
like not all of yeah yeah it's just like
a it's also very like different instant
in its difficulty you know great flavor
is your
you're not necessarily it's not a not
like a pattern recognition thing that
relies more on knowing is there a death
count for this do you want to admit how
many times you've died if you guys are
wondering how many times I've died like
total in the game yes they do count your
debts for you oh I won't spoil yep oh
I'll show you guys
after we finished this area how many I
know like it will count after you beat
the level it will add oil add to your
total but if yeah I guess we can we can
see if anyone in the check and guess how
many times in I mean I think you died
like 50 times in last like five minutes
yes
I had a nickel for every time Joey died
pretty rich is the whole city like this
or is this just an especially hazardous
neighborhood also I didn't ask you and I
wasn't paying attention is this is
besides so this is the the b-side to the
city that we just the first city to play
helper guest 856 for eight
my arrow said my friend recommended
blood-borne to me as a joke expect me to
get frustrated and quit but then it
became on my favorite games ever joke's
on that death timers pretty good I mean
although in this scheme I guess it's not
necessarily a bad thing it's just yeah
it's like your your deaths are all part
of like the learning process they even
they even mention that in the game
itself
protecting the game but says you
guessing over 1,300 I would say yeah
I'll say more is definitely more oh no
the first platformer yeah
Mario I would say I would say like Mario
was first for me Mario World in in my
kind of discovering that oh I can do
this a lot faster if I really tried like
like I never really took it seriously
but just kind of experimenting with with
running the game like just try and see
how fast I can get through each for the
levels like back in like late 90s like I
know what speed Renny was at the time or
anything I'm sure it already is like I
think the a lot of the people who worked
on on the game um they're pretty they
like participate in like speedruns and
like a part of the community in which i
think is pretty cool
I will say that it is much more than
1-thousand you said you put about 40
hours yeah 40 hours like tolls of that
you know it does include me just kind of
sitting at my desk like doing other
stuff while it's raining but I would say
like told playtime maybe closer like 30
35 all right got that one Errol said I
love Mario World I love you oh she's
Island first Mario game I ever finished
Yoshi's Island it was also the first
game Mario game I ever finished so we're
now connected forever
was one of my favorite Mario games of
all time
- crying Mario you know plenty of it
apparently like you she's on is also one
of the more like prolific speedrunning
games because of how difficult it is
like run that game apparently
I'm a through the besides good job Joey
that's first one not too bad right when
we died maybe like 20 times on that one
[Music]
we got through that one dying this not
bad is it was there anyone that got
closer to to guessing nope anywhere near
pelipper pelipper says 30 hours times 60
or 30 hours over 60 times 10 that's a
minute you know the last math class I
took was pre Cal when I was like 600 an
hour 30 hours that's only eight is that
1800 it was 18,000 you know should we
just tell them all right I'll go do it
so in the game we can also take a look
at your journal here which will kind of
give you like an overview of the levels
that you've done so at the bottom there
you can see a total death count
besides and regular levels combined it's
twelve thousand two hundred thanks so
there you go yes that was the celestial
resort no so the resort has 24 of almost
2,500 deaths
oh no oh on the B side at least yeah
yow all right let's actually let's let's
do that one do you feel like you don't
feel like I'm gonna die Concord I want
to say yes because I did this one
earlier on then like some of the other
b-sides but if things go to hell then we
can we can always we can always back out
we can always try a different point I
don't know I feel like we're all bad at
math in this chat right now although you
know I don't think I'd want to know how
many times I've died knows I'm gay Oh in
some games yeah maybe this
[Music]
Oh first screen were already there it's
just trouble oh I love the song by the
way this is where you died all 2400
times yeah this is when I was like okay
this is this is how difficult the game
can get I see what's going on here cuz
it makes you it starts making you do
jumps that like you never thought were
possible before yeah like doing that
what going from one side of that little
thing and like going on to the other
side in such a short span of time
[Music]
this should be an Android ain't move
easily I would say it would be difficult
on such a small
unless you were playing on a tablet
maybe hmm even still it's like when you
need that precision I can't imagine not
having like analog controls you can feel
and you can get controllers for I know
but things like yeah like just people
normally aren't going to have that yeah
[Music]
you started like flashing red when you
start running on stamina yeah I noticed
that that's a nice thing they know it's
like a bar
[Music]
our Jean says this is what challenges
real pros let's find out Joey is a real
pro right now that's supposed to speak
yes arrow I feel for you I'm also mental
game vet says did you like the nod to
other classic games Nathan listen
yes so there's an easter egg like later
on the game that's a callback to Super
Mario Brothers 3 this apparently that's
Matt me the guy oh my god that was the
last joke that's his like favorite game
of all time so he has like a really cool
little thing I won't spoil it again
because it's pretty cool I like the
campfire yeah
[Music]
Phares to cat thank you so much for
coming to the stream maybe next time I
will be playing folk G I saw you say
that earlier in the chat as always we
appreciate you so one thing I really
like about the game is that you can you
can after done you can start off pretty
much immediately yes there's no like
like there's no there's no really wait
time but things like all the UH all the
obstacles and everything is like kind of
synced up perfectly so that right when
you write when you start moving you can
like immediately begin the run and like
you can time your jumps perfectly like
right from the start this is the music
in this level is really exciting I have
to say I'm just like in my head
but I'm the type of person that if I'm
having a hard time yeah actually
sometimes have to turn the music really
that's what keeps me moving that's like
that's a few Smith girl over well that's
what I'm like okay I need to like turn
the music down for just a minute and
focus
[Music]
the arch and I think I'm going to stick
with Mario I mean it's a safe bet
who've I'm with Joey and I need a visa
to get in the groove you heard the song
da friends is a bit like Mega Man music
yeah that's all thinking yeah chiptune
so they're like Elsa give the from Sonic
Romania or that's just like in recent
memory but like one take one of the
levels in their studio AAPIs it's like
reminiscent of this one I think
point when you go up to us we like it
felt like a queen up it's like a and you
have to knock both of them in order to
[Music]
not that
[Music]
so nothing you only have one one - in
the air so you've gotta make sure you
use it wisely
oh I'm good
along with the blob
[Music]
I'm like dialed and like crossing my
fingers free right now
[Music]
[Music]
oh that's core is it course he's gonna
be there
no panic dashes allow Joey no panic
dashes I mean I wouldn't miss a few
panic dashes myself
think I wasted that one no I need I need
I need the -
[Music]
Oh oh yeah that was really instead of
time
I feel like if I watch the full speed
run of this where there was like almost
note that I would be like wow wow I
think so I think the current record is
43 minutes going through the whole the
entire game with no death
pretty sure there's no death oh you
almost said easy and I was like well
it's like okay it's not I would say easy
okay this one here GG easy
[Music]
yeah that was I was accurate that was a
bad feeling that's like the internal
yeah all the time i watching you
actually
[Music]
doctrine says gbq for this game is 42
minutes that's God like currently like
you know it's gonna get it's gonna only
get faster from there
[Music]
oh my god that was actually really
impressive doing thank you
[Music]
so has anybody have you guys picked up
Celeste or are you going to watching
Joey keeping your mind oh I'm gonna make
it or are there any other platformers
right
notable mentions
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
my brain is I've heard a little - boo
[Music]
oh okay good sweet so this was like it
was about here I think was when I
realized okay you know how you can uh
you can climb Melissa but you can also
grab onto it by like holding our I
started realizing you don't even need to
fold onto this you can just jump off of
everything and still complete levels so
you don't have to use your like the wall
cling like yeah it's like it's it's good
to use if you like or are stuck
somewhere and like you - you're like
sliding off but like it's really not
necessary which is it that just makes
that changes that changed a lot for me I
think
[Music]
the big game changer
I guess in the way that like I
approached the game
[Music]
[Music]
joking have you heard of slime son on
Twitch
I have such wine boom you know Harrelson
Becky is currently with you again I
hadn't heard of it myself
no I've never heard of it
[Music]
[Music]
he said it would came out earlier on 17
and it was very overlooked 117 Wow
such a small window take that back this
time you can though
immediately check that back to
[Music]
sometimes they take my time yeah I'm
holding my breath watching my kids by
breathing air grounded dream it looks
amazing but is it meat boy level that
was scream but became unenjoyable as no
I think this is like a good amount of
difficulty like in my opinion like I
don't think it ever gets really
frustrating in the same way that Super
Meat Boy did yeah and like I would
consider myself
I'm not terrible platformers I'm I'm I
would say if average skill level I'm not
Joey good but I'm not like who hears
yeah Joey it's not like the pinnacle of
skill but he was quite quite good as a
game I would say he's definitely
talented at platformers I wouldn't say
that it's like a Forte I'm but I was I'm
an average player of these games and
Super Meat Boy did get too difficult at
a certain point for me but I was very
invested in the love story so actually I
watched somebody finish the game
[Music]
let me do this one
yeah this game looks a lot more
forgiving than meatboy I would agree was
liking but I think it does it makes you
feel like I guess better about dying
maybe it's the music or maybe it's the
lack of blood maybe yeah like it doesn't
antagonize you I feel like in the same
way to see Super Meat Boy did sometimes
yeah
well lucky for you goob you can play
this platformer for the story if you
want to it has the easy mode well I
don't want to call it that this is yeah
this mode hold your hand through the
game a little bit I would be lying if I
said I never played a game on easy mode
before oh my god sometimes you just want
to experience the beauty
[Music]
I have this game and I have 500 deaths
in the hotel is that lower or higher
than way you have Jerry it's uh a little
bit lower but I guess like my first time
through the hotel maybe it was it was
around there
[Music]
if I don't like the word passion they
call it a swiss casual
[Music]
there are certain games I was just
thinking about this specialist game is
on Steam right now yeah there are
certain games that are especially you're
not meant to definitely one of them
I actually tried to play Ori and the
blind forest do any platformer is not
going to work well on a keyboard just
doesn't feel right something about not
using your thumb I guess yeah like
hopping back and forth so I actually did
attempt it sort of so if you are
I'm thinking you know probably the best
place to play it Joey ponds and also
just being able to play this on the go
cuz like yeah being able just clear like
a short segment of the game when little
by little is always really nice yeah you
can say that about any switch game like
I feel like that's a good way to play a
lot but I don't want to make any
assumption that's rude I came back
playing on PC Xbox controller that is
how I play most of my
I have one of those legs they're pretty
all right it's like a rock candy
controller
[Music]
yeah goodbye agree portability is almost
also about the switch and at first I
really thought that the battery life was
gonna be a deal-breaker for me because
it only lasts like three hours but then
I realized that there's really never a
situation where I'm in a place for more
than three hours where I can't recharge
yeah like even on airplane airplane if
you don't have an outlet on your plane
you can always go back it's really yeah
it's it's seems to be okay he also me
there goes mad - sure
[Music]
yeah you little batteries are pretty you
get fairly deep
line holds like a fair amount of charge
[Music]
Erol this is true.i but I will say I
have played Super Mario Odyssey
I took a play it was c5 our play and I
actually it was my first time playing
miss moriata see I've gone the play and
I helped I played the whole time oh my
god
[Music]
you said this guy wasn't that bad and
now I really don't believe you know
initially he was he was okay okay
I think we're getting close to the end
of this one
animate I like this Oh welcome to the
stream we are playing Celeste
[Music]
timing is
I was like there's a little bit of
slowdown as he like such a dashing that
you sure I think someone said shouts
appeal
it's one of the other characters in game
he's one of the travels that unique like
while climbing mountains so basically
well the story of the game is that
you're this girl who just who decides to
climb Mount Celeste and on your way up
to to the taki meet Theo who like helps
you out in certain areas
go mine and the mountain is [ __ ]
metaphorical in a way right now the game
does focus on some pretty curious topics
like depression and anxiety
dealing with the struggles of life and
so I think the mountain is supposed to
be up in there for which
using for a lot of people it's actually
a relatable story whether yeah
[Music]
course round the door opens
is it some pious work yes yes it is
there we go that's you bad hands a
little clammy joy cards
first time I went through it much fewer
deaths ooh okay so we've seen that one
I feel like see what's a good one to go
to next mirror temple well hello there
welcome to the stream
we're playing Celeste it is a platformer
by Matt makes games that makes games yes
yeah actually just to hear the music
I'll go back to the old site b-side
fuller I think you can buy on soundcloud
it's also available to stream on Spotify
as well oh nice I love that I love when
game music happens to be on Spotify I
recently found one or two just the first
yeah so I don't know if that hits a
nostalgia spot for you guys but if it
does those playlists do exist on Spotify
bless whoever made them going
hakim Corbett says I kind of hate the
hotel manager guy not because of the
flying head he just whines so much do
you feel that way I originally I didn't
till like there's like some dialogue
between him and Celeste or at him and
your main character Madeline that like
kind of explains his like personality
which i think is it's like a really cool
way to do it again spoil the story or
anything
Dizzy's death says chiptune music 16-bit
art style and tackling depression that's
just one indie game bingo it did that
those are a lot of comedies individually
as it tackle them all beautifully which
is what earned it such a higher abuse
score I think if you go and look at the
reviews across the board it did really
well yeah pretty much no matter who
reviewed it or where you guys can check
out our review wrote it
Randall Hyatt no don't break my heart he
says they don't have all the songs all
right well the playlist I found had most
of the ones I remembered and loved I
didn't like cross-check that one
specifically but there are some pretty
good comprehensive play with us out
there so
Erol since I would love games had
psychological problems we also check
that out I did major in psychology
though some people a little bias I think
it's interesting I always find it
interesting to see games tackle tough
topics like that and I think my games
are gonna continue to explore those
areas in storytelling as you know the
space changes reality improving there
was even like a Sundance Film Festival
version for like VR movies a couple like
two years before don't remember so like
I don't know seeing like storytelling in
psychology play out games is gonna be I
think
is this one of your top games I mean so
far I mean can you or February 1st 2nd
February to start a February shadows are
back my demons
Ximena lemur hello welcome how are we
today
I would be like pulling my hair out
right now because this scheme is quite
challenging
yeah
salmon old this is less it is a
platformer by Matt makes games he made
titanfall tension power hall tower sorry
my head did one of those things where I
replaced words with others roots
towerfall ascension which you might
remember as being a sort of like
survival of the fittest platformer one
for players if you use like the ball
chain dashing among jump on people say
you jump some people's heads
similar some similar mechanics appear in
both games
he also has eventually made and not just
him Matt makes games into the studio but
studio has many people that work to make
these games he's got quite a few
platformers actually yeah towerfall was
just one of the most popular ones that
people latched onto it came out in 2013
originally but the poll was launched
wasn't until a bit later
this is like his big fellow yeah quite a
lot of attention right angles here this
is my happiest day ever
well we're happy to be here on your
happiest day ever
immediately died the next screen animate
Caju says do you like Dragonball
fighters II I personally have them play
fighters II yet but I love it - I feel
like the general response to you
Dragonball Aires he has been very
possible
yes I'm it oldest game is quite hard is
the games are commonly referred to as I
think like I just recently heard about
like platformers where it's like my
pores but the main idea is that you're
gonna be dying a whole lot Oh what are
the coin the term platformer hello who's
first guy who was like you know this is
platformer
[Music]
there we go
too bad right d Trejo 91 says oh you
know skelet not let the dying get to you
so much yeah
also your name D Trejo reminded me of
Danny are you Danny Trejo that's what
I'm asking right now James lo hello mark
the screen right here this is like this
is one I realize okay this game is
making me do stuff it's like insane
yes Eric
Wow I feel like I should have known that
oh yeah that's right that's where I
heard it from Wow well please don't tell
them that we didn't know that right oh
that was that was cool that was fun yeah
[Music]
almost we sit at the top oh that is the
crystal heart and so that's like that
basically signifies the end of the
b-side
[Music]
dizzi death off-topic ultra carpet is
amazing please no spoilers in the chat
but I do hear great things about it
[Music]
because you can't be on you can't be
over that well it's actually I haven't
broken again I broken a controller
before yeah it was it was like as a
computer oh I think I was the final boss
in that it was complete BS it was clear
that this was that it was just unfair
yeah
[Music]
all right I'm amazed that it was
checking so that's really reason why I
don't really play against like the
computer a lot of fighting canes yeah
yeah let's see where should we should
mirror temple
have you ever tossed a Wemo at somebody
or something no I have it
controller add somebody luckily nobody
ever got me that mad and a multiplayer
game well though the mirror temple chalk
the b-side here I really like this one
too so I feel like the cassette
reference is lost on a lot of like
younger gamers I guess so yeah like they
might think that's just like a thing in
this game like they said P time but
purpose I'm feel like most of you guys
in here totally
be sad to have different science yeah
the different size of the consent
different songs
so it's just a reference to that
here's all the spikes
these bubbles so these ones will shoot
you Scheffer direction until you dash
out of them oops or until you hit a wall
so these things are here which will move
if you - so you can use them to like
propel yourself upward
[Music]
this song is chill yeah I agree
they're speaking of games with great
music yeah what is your favorite game
soundtrack of all time of all time what
is it can't think about man I don't know
I feel like some people in here probably
gonna say undertale of your tale
I don't know about all-time but I still
really like up heads like that you have
music
pretty uh pretty jazzy
Jet Set Radio future
yeah coffee rush was very good at all
that's hard I do really like Megaman to
music a lot and it might just be like a
nostalgia thing there's something I'm
not really quite sure
[Music]
Skyrim songs are epic my room song all
the time you know I'd be like wait
preparing for battle
whoa that's specific sonic mania
hydrocity zone act to to specifically
I like you Matsu he does like a Final
Fantasy Final Fantasy game yeah I've
always wanted to go see it goes concerts
yeah like
[Music]
Oh unexpected
[Music]
work
Oh
[Music]
just push me down
hey insane cannon welcome to the stream
thanks for showing up
I very much appreciate your presence
here
[Music]
nice
I say after watching you do all the
b-sides I think it's maybe giving me
false confidence and my ability I'm
gonna be like I just watched you all of
you it's not that bad forest just barely
play Super Smash Brothers yes yes not
not like competitively or that seriously
just keep going okay I'm also like one
of those stereotypical like you're just
trying to copy them or swallow them and
jump off the ledge yeah I like doing
that we don't
sandal I will say pup chief for me
personally that's only because I have it
for tonight I put about I want to say
like 120 hours or so far not the same
I'm not thank for that
I just addicted to it I'm gonna download
for it nice and sweet and give it a go
I'm gonna try not to be biased and a lot
of people who are like super addicted to
pub - you're like it's for casuals and
thing I'm not that's not how I feel so
far so we'll see we'll see how I feel
about it
I'm not trying to be biased I love the
fact that it's free-to-play that's cool
can't hate on that
Kirby as a Nintendo character in general
is delightful he is uh you know I'm not
it's just the heat yeah makes sense yeah
I don't know if they ever officially
assigned him agender boys he made oh
he's wearing shoes or is that just part
of his like like Anatomy these are
actually not shoes those are the shape
of speed then I've just been assuming
that Kirby wears shoes this whole time
I'm having quite an existential dilemma
about Kirby's life right now Kirby Kirby
is the gum stuck under the table
ask you guys because I can't play those
beans but I can still watch ah well we
like to play variety of games here so oh
I miss Kirby is a homie Kirby is a homie
according to shot right now Kirby is a
homie he's a friend
sounds like Kirby is like our writer
died
I miss a comment that I wanted to read I
don't know if it didn't appear and it
was like a fortnight versus pub G
comment I think somewhere I think it's
just somebody that said none of them
either is that the right hand it was
that a trick question
this is what I'm getting at here
and make ah who my favorite a Nintendo
character is also Toon Link I've loved
two links so much she's my favorite and
I might be a little biased I love
winwaker a ton so yeah but a few
linkages free kirby is a baby star
warrior who woke up too early
he's a what I don't know Errol said
that's what he remembers from watching
the MA
I'm gonna start referring to him as baby
star warrior totally forgot about that
show I remember watching it I have the
first season on DVD for something like I
just randomly bought him
wind wakers might be rich all the game
Errol whoa okay so Errol and I have two
things in common now it was he also said
that Yoshi Yoshi's Island was his first
Mario platformers I mean Mario game he
completed yeah my favorites and also
that wind wakers his favorites all those
super - man I like your style
a game that I agree with you the
conversation about pub scene for a night
I think is just because there - it's
very very popular games right now
because the battle royale thing and so
that just instantly puts them in the
same category oh but I agree there are
different mechanics - for tonight from
what I've seen and I don't necessarily
think that it's fair to say that there
you know
exactly the same yeah it's still look
like it's still very very new genre yeah
gonna have to figure out like what works
what doesn't
he said Keith Richards's he played sport
night but he probably liked pub chick
better if he could get on the ps4 I am a
PC fan so I love my ps4 also but when it
comes to shooters yeah so much better on
PCs so I always play single-player games
on my playstation always have always
will
my competitive and online games boys to
PC so angel is smexy says any thoughts
on dusting to I think you'd have to ask
eight a are residency to he will be able
to give you much more poignant thoughts
about destiny to than I will but I think
it could be summed up as not enough
content right it's like yeah weird
issues with throttling experience
yeah Bunji why why you know make the
same fun general discourse right now
so are these squiggly things fire or are
they like tentacle months they're like
appreciated tentacles so this is like
the second half of them--are temple
where everything is like you go through
the same thing except everything's like
completely different like this ro
version yeah you still have like the
same layout but
he butchered says I do think before and
I might have a steeper learning curve
which is building and but I will say as
a counter to that is that there are
things about pop G that I think offers
deeper learning curve and for tonight
for instance there's like a ton of
attachments for your weapons that you
don't have to deal with important I
again haven't played for at night so
I'll let you know my full opinions when
I actually dive into the game my first
stream which I did a couple weeks ago
with Eric I played battlegrounds maybe
my next my next J will play some
battlegrounds our warning button
khaleesi says go Joey go
so love this music it's soothing enough
for me to make it through all these
deaths it's very soothing I like this
this is probably my favorite track so
far and I gotta say it's like the the
swag enos of the saxophone yeah
gaming butter I didn't get to say hello
before but welcome I see you here I like
your username
Oh thread the needle close
[Music]
[Music]
dang it
[Music]
yes Keith I make sense the endgame
base-building thing is definitely
interesting components that pub G does
not have
I'm curious to see how I think feel
about it once I played it I'm always
hesitant to give my opinions about games
I haven't dived into Annika I guess on a
competitive level
I can see em in the chat right now huh
well thank you for the encouragement
just beat it
[Music]
Joey is very good at platformers
president putt from erratics as he's
coming cup to known to known he's also
playing the b-side to give him a break
the hardest
but dacron says he's getting passenger
rates while watching his steps
that's just Joey transferring his own
rage where is the switch oh dang
Joshua Lissa's I don't know how you're
saying calm I'd be losing my mind right
now
he's silently losing his mind I have
been for a long time learning I guess
once you accept the depths is not being
a punishment yeah then it's not it then
it's like okay it's fine
the goal is not to die less it's just to
learn that your learn the
don't need me yeah challenge does I just
accept in okay restart
right over the door
just trying to jump on them
keep me better thank you for coming by n
we don't know when use them either but
we're happy that you remembered us or
Sarah saw the southern notification or
for whatever reason you're here
scary
[Music]
realize those spikes or no no you're
just dashing out those are not yeah
give me butter ask how many languages do
you guys speak I speak almost five
I speak one just barely
[Laughter]
can you play the assist mode in the
b-sides
I want to say yes just because like you
turn on the assist mode like right at
the beginning if you still want to like
tread these eyes like yeah I would
assume it's it's still there
what would you call that fisheries name
what I call yeah no joke no I don't know
serious question
ran behind my favorite color joy Kahn is
the yellow joy pond I really like the
spittoon colored ones yeah they just
start they just released them in America
yes maybe yellow one is from it was like
one of the first alternate colors I
think in America yeah
is it is it forearm it was forearms
guess it was
a jhe love we are playing Celeste on a
switch
Adrian I agree this does have axiom
verge bit style yeah I think especially
this stage right here yeah the colors
the general gross --mess of one of some
of the enemies yeah played a little bit
yeah axiom verge though different terms
but it's more of a hey buddy come on go
get this done now there's lots of stuff
I need to be aware of
what is that thing that's my friends
trapped in the crystal I need to bring
him along with me to beat this level you
gotta make sure he he doesn't fall and
die and neither do all hi
still double-jump throw it at them but
it doesn't do it just kinda like that
make some bounce away yeah I tried to
keep count of the depths but I lost that
like 4000 for this run I know for in the
very beginning we talked about deaf
counting I was like
[Music]
mr. Van Damme favorite Metroid yeah
I don't know I have actually I have not
played a lot of Metroid I really do like
super though
who's our biggest Metroid fan let's say
Peter
[Music]
he's got a spawn back so fast as soon as
you kill them it would drive me insane
actually
I see
I just realized that eyeballs I've been
looking at you the whole time oh yeah
yeah they follow you toss them into the
abyss it was your friend Joey
at least you don't have to deal like a
permanent story consequence of losing
him yeah
No yeah
[Music]
a white whale once again pushed off
alright leave them there and deal with
this No
so I was thinking about getting the I
think it's the Pikachu
yes Studios yeah no one looks pretty
cool so a few years ago I want to say I
might be wrong here Billy forty years
ago they came out with a yeah I remember
that one a head like was face on there
or something on the like completely
covered up the the backside with the
yellow yes and I was so sad that I
didn't get it and he's actually really
expensive now this one right here
a little bit less bulky
enjoy the silence yes this game is on PC
would suggest playing the controller
achieving him across these gaps just
that Ziya finishing this part of my own
Oh God Oh at least you made it to it
really you have to be justify enough
they're arrows and he still has a
special pokémon action game boy color it
doesn't work for it's so cool to have it
is cool
there's definitely people out there he
could fix that bad
I still have my team boy color teal I
have a neon green one he'll know it so
works maybe just needs batteries
woman okay Julius gadshill gadge is one
of our social guys yes probably catch I
have this inside joke where I tried to
explain to him what the color Cheil was
[Music]
like how do you describe color at all I
showed him examples of teal I think it
is that our array at the end of our
stream now we can wrap it up with maybe
one more besides
yeah most difficult be sad actually I
don't think I have the most difficult
one the very last one unlocked but I do
have oh wait I do have it unlocked oh my
god and go into this blind if we can we
can just spend like 10 minutes I want to
see a first I want to see a first time
be side with Joey no deaths on it yet
alright let's go yes it's from an old
egm magazine they used to have a car
they used to have a comic in occult soon
Qian and in one of them they were
deciding they're trying to figure out
whether or not video games cause
violence in people in kids oh wow I am
missing one heart so you need every
single one of those hearts in order to
in order to unlock this last part
unfortunately we're not gonna be able to
get to that one but can you figure out
what the heart you're missing do you
know yeah I'm pretty sure it's the one
or check the yes the one on the summit
that one's very I don't even know where
that one is
let's reflection just go to the b-side
for the summit one I like this one's
pretty cool cool is this the heart you
need no well you actually it's it's here
somewhere I just don't know where it is
I don't think we're gonna be able to get
to it
also if you guys can explain what she'll
is for - I would very much appreciate it
thank you I love how a platform so
pelion it makes it so much more like
exciting I can't get up there see how
far we get with this and like next ten
minutes
a tiny little window
right to the spice yeah
Hill is the powerhouse of the sound
I don't know what that means I'm with it
slow okay
sometimes it's for the best
oh I can go under that I'm doing that
thing where I'm holding my breath
oh just barely
no God doesn't know what Telos
hey gadget old pillows
right ooh that's ladies that's yours
yeah start person let me out here a
little bit oh boy
ooh let's bake news chills nothing like
purple you know that purple process
really okay I really like you actually
oh gaming butter thank you I'm if you're
being sarcastic cause I don't think you
are so talented you serve way more subs
like hopefully thank you we hope you
return before
[Music]
[Music]
there we go oh wow that was so cool just
like nasus so how many times did it take
you to actually think remember that
[Music]
make it know that's what's the point
that would be cool just try for that one
[Music]
yeah whoa that was crazy that was really
good day maybe he'll as the friends we
made along the way
like all these obscure better sense of
what feeling uber just going like the
literal sense yes green or blue yeah
yeah boobs on the right track
[Music]
[Music]
oh that was it Errol it makes sense you
don't think about it that's how I do my
life fair if you just don't like yeah
mix it all don't think about it
Henry trove you're watching on YouTube
right now I does everybody have access
to like the multi view on say like all
the different chats will think so
basically we're stream right now to
YouTube twitch and site so we have
multiple chats that we're looking at so
if we're saying something that doesn't
make sense it's probably because we're
talking to people who are just hanging
out another chat if you have a link to
where they can see multiple multiple
chats
all right I don't know pull up the
twitch window and say oh yeah yeah pull
the second window and switch window say
house no has its own chat yes there's a
chat YouTube chat and twitch chat I wish
there was so easy way to show everybody
but
oh my god
insane Kenan is that like a tear in
space or time that you travel through
the game it has not been determined but
I believe it's jell-o jell-o all right
space jello these jello time and space
Joe timey wimey space jello muscle
memory whatever helps you know a straw
with sprinkles it's like funfetti space
jello
funfetti
but resin confetti fan in the office
somewhere are you like anti fatty
because that's that's questionable
that's I I don't know how I went home I
think er that I wouldn't call myself
unfit e-band
exactly but you know I appreciate it for
what it is although I'm you know what
I'm gonna have to like buy my time here
and disagree with you guys
I don't like cookies that only cookies
or maybe feedback so he's like funfetti
cookies but I'm thinking I know you can
make funfetti cookies but oh boy goop I
just might have made myself the screws
your funfetti i don't know
breather there - thanks that's
[Music]
he misses the developer cause of dream
boxes like that it is a very imaginative
name Bob Jones once on your favorite
Celeste oh I would say I really like the
second one the old site has like someone
best music and I really like that's
where you that first introduces you to
just mechanic with the dream boxes I
think it's like probably one of the best
I can
I know I can - out of that I just
forgetting to do that you get the first
saxophone music that was it was the
b-side for the one that we just did the
mirror temple yes
yes the mir temple music was good both
sides of america morning
about we finish this one up in the
street if I can even get otherwise I'll
still also be here when the sweet man
was just trying to finish it nice -
there you go
that's the panic - the I fear who
brought up and chat earlier bet whoops
suppose
it really does take like spacing in
precision like to just the right and I
see
[Music]
there we go good run alright so there's
more to this one this is like near the
end where you kind of go through a lot
of the other parts of the game but we'll
stop it here just because what one my
thumb's are starting to hurt a little
bit from pressing so hard but I think I
press this one miss big yeah alright
guys
uh-huh thank you for coming to the
stream today and you know playing some
Celeste
yeah it was fun Joey you know thanks for
playing that awesomely yeah anytime
platformers go
yes if you guys want to read more about
Celeste or see more about Celeste we do
have a really great review on it I ran
by a spur days he goes a little bit more
into his thoughts and opinions about the
storyline and some other answers that
maybe we didn't get to give you in the
stream as always thank you for joining
this is your last moment you have any
questions comments sir you want to you
know tell gadje what teal is this is
yeah I think I think he's he should find
on his own himself other other round up
today's conversation does Kirby have
feet I think we should do a feature on
that can scared to look more into it but
yeah yeah you should as the resident one
of our social media producers here I
need to tell you guys to follow us on
Facebook Twitter Instagram if you read
Apple news in the morning we're on that
too
I'll you know Twitter's the tweets mmm
that's when you'll know when new
features go up when we're streaming you
know general themes about things so
again thanks everybody
you have any final words Joey this is
good try it you enjoy cons and yeah well
also eighty I don't know how to turn
this thing off you coming here help help
would be outro yeah okay thanks Joe
alright bye guys it's one of them
alright
you